On screen text, a fusion of both worlds on two parallel worlds.
Welcome back. This week we're going to go through using the Psoa lunging system
to build better balance in the horses before we even get on. The reason why I
like this system is because it works the whole body of the horse without the
influence of the rider's positive or negative consequences. So here we have
the setup of the Psoa. On the lowest setting we have the pulleys underneath
attached to the girth, a pulley at the bit, a pulley low down and on the
surcingle, and the fleece piece is right underneath the tail, below the hip, and
above the hawk. Before you begin with the Psoa, your horse needs to have
proficient lunging skills with a bridle and a halter and know all the commands
that you are using to walk, trot, canter, slow down, speed up, close the circle and
open the circle. After that point the horse can go in side reins as a one of
two parts to build towards the Psoa lunging system. When you're teaching the
horses to go in this system, make sure they're going forward so they don't get
stuck and make your decisions very clear so that they know where you're going.
Some common reactions to the Psoa is running through the pulley on the mouth
so you'll see the horse's head come up and run forward and hit the bit really
hard. That's a common reaction, just allow the horse to experience its own
consequences for those reactions. Number two is they feel like they've been tied
and they can't move, so sometimes you might have to lead the horse in front of
you and lead them around like a little pony ride to indicate that they in fact
can move but it's inside of a little box. You might want to loosen the Psoa a lot
more if your horse is feeling more stuck. And then the third one, which is this
example with this horse, is they scoot away from that bum fleece and they try
to run and go faster to try and fix the feeling of the bum fleece making sure
that their hind legs aren't sprawling out the back. So this is a very normal
reaction as well and you'll see some of the corrections I make with this horse
to help her understand that she can do that with her back legs. So it's very
common for the horses to kick out at the back fleece as well and it's in a very
safe place that it doesn't become, it doesn't slide up or down and it doesn't
become misplaced. So if you're feeling like the Psoa is moving around while
the horse is having these reactions, be sure to adjust it and move it to a
safer place. If you're only feeling comfortable teaching your horse in the
walk first, then moving to the trot, then moving to the canter, that's totally okay
and sufficient for your level and the horse's level. Some great tips for horses
that are scooting themselves away from the Psoa is to bring the circle in
smaller. Keep the whip out, keep it active, keep the energy up so they don't move
into getting stuck but that you're telling them that they can slow down and
there's a space for them to step. Number two, if your horse is getting stuck and
you're leading it around, you might have to do this in over the course of three
days to build up to the canter and it might take you a little while to build
up to the canter if they're very very much feeling stuck. If your horse is
reactive by pulling on the bit, you may have to come under their bum with the
whip and encourage them to go forward so that they can find the energy or find
the space to go over their wither as opposed to scooting up and trying to run
free from the bit. So after your horse is trained and ready for their lunging
advancement to use the Psoa, you may start at walk and if your horse is
sufficiently lessening, you may ask for transitions more promptly to get them
more used to the boundaries which the Psoa is providing. These systems are
super good for creating left and right balance and forward and back balance in
the horse by engaging the loins at the top of the lower lumbar or in front of
the hip area of the horse. This particular horse has a tendency to throw
its hind legs out the back and evade good downward transitions so as expected
in the Psoa in the lunge lesson that we're giving her, it's most difficult for
her to do a downward transition since the Psoa will not allow her to sprawl
her legs out the back so therefore she feels like she needs to keep going
forward. Don't necessarily discipline your horse for this, let them experience
the boundaries on their own and just simply make the circle smaller and allow
them to learn on their own where their body is and how to control their own
body. This connection is so important for the horses to learn. We can't always
be able to see from the saddle unless we have someone videoing us of our effect
on how we we teach the horses to do this with their bodies so lunging, groundwork,
Psoa work can be so good for watching and seeing where your horse is accurate
and where it's not. Partway through your lesson you will notice the horses
intending to stretch way down, that's an excellent sign that means that they've
been activating, they've been contracting their lower back muscles to push their
back up and that means that you've done a great job. When you're first teaching
the horses this make sure to keep the sessions short and attainable as this is
quite an upgrade to fitness for each horse.